from calorie council portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between shake shack in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk burgers come in two sizes
single and double
and in the us our shake shack burgers
also come in single or double
we're gonna weigh the double shack
burger to find out if it's actually the
same size in the uk as it is in the us
oh man ours weighs a lot less
significantly less what's up with that
shake shack
in the uk we can only get fries in one
size and this is it
in the u.s we also have only one size of
fries what i meant to say was
let's see how much they weigh
so our portion of fries came to around
188 grams
what this 188 ours is like a little over
100 like when i say 105 i might be
generous
it's a lot less so far the fries
and the burger have been significantly
smaller than the uk i thought we were
the ones with the big portions
drinks from a uk shake shack come in two
sizes regular
and large the u.s we also have only two
fountain drink sizes regular and large
we're going to measure them to find out
how much is actually in these
so a regular drink from a uk shake shack
has about 400 milliliters in it
why should in a big one first
little over 16 ounces
it fits that's good it has gone slightly
over the scales
i'm gonna in my infinite wisdom assume
that's around 600 milliliters
give or take a few
is that 16. jump to the little guy
huh six and a half 16 plus
six is 24 right
22. and we'll give it a half so 22 and a
half fluid ounces for the large
milkshakes in the uk only come in one
size we're not sure what it is so again
we're going to measure it
in the u.s our shakes also come in one
size
i mean this thing might be to the line
16 ounces
uh-oh got some bad news connor
looks like it's a little under 16 ounces
unfortunately in the uk you can also get
beer from shake shack this normally
comes in a serving of
one pint however unfortunately due to
the reduced menu from the pandemic we
couldn't get one today
the shake shacks in the u.s are still
serving beer
so the ones we got to go were cans at
the 12 ounce and the 16 ounce
i'm gonna assume since it's the same
size cup that this
is a pint fun pipe fact for you
our plants in the uk are actually bigger
than your pints in the us we use
imperial measurements and our pints are
around
19 ounces whereas yours are 16. if all
pints are magically half to size
i'm just drinking twice as much i've
never stopped to think
how many fluid ounces in a beer it's
like
get me out of here what about hot dogs
well a hot dog from a uk shake shack is
six
and a half inches long
what in the heck is this
they cut the hot dog in half cursed
image
am i getting punked here first five guys
and now shake shack
i i'm i get it i'm fighting a losing
battle i guess
normal hot dogs yeah i mean five guys
reached out to me
haven't heard back from them though at
the recording of this shake shack you're
on the list now too
you're on the list now too i want to
know what's going on these hot dogs
i did not bring the tape measure but
the good people at apple have an app
that measures stuff for us this shoot of
course
is sponsored by apple
all right so i'm going to measure this
hot dog
this is actually working six and a half
inches
thank you apple and it weighs
126 grams it looks like it's like
exactly on 125.
and last but by no means least shake
shack in the uk and the us are both
known for being quite dog
friendly and as such you can get dog
treats
these are red velvet dog treats and they
come in packs of five
they were saying there's a red velvet i
don't know what art is supposed to be
oh it's got the shake shack logo on you
see that
oh i don't like how they smell
i'll do a little bit like a communion
wafer
i'm not getting red velvet now we're
going to get the expert opinion on dog
treats
[Music]
hey mabel hi yeah there's chicks on the
floor
wait this is mabel the dog and she's
gonna taste test the treats for us
mabel yum
this is mabel the dog and we're gonna
get her thoughts on the dog treats from
shake
what do you think mabel wow not bad not
bad
do you taste red velvet no
i don't if you taste the red velvet but
she seems to be enjoying it so good job
guys
bring me the dogs
yeah hey paw what do you think
three three you want a big one
how is it how is it how is that needs
salt
i mean you see that you see what i
talked about before about like these
like they're like
almost like those matzah crackers you
get those really like tasteless ones
that
like your mom gets because she doesn't
want you eating all that salt or
whatever
i don't know if this would be my top
favorite go-to dog treats but
in a pinch yeah
so what do you have to do during
quarantine
unfortunately shake shack in the uk
doesn't disclose any of its nutritional
information
however we can get nutritional
information in the u.s so
let's start with the calories in a
standard meal if you get
the double shack burger and the fries
and a chocolate shake
you're looking at 2010 calories which is
just a little bit over your entire
daily recommended allowance so just eat
this every day once
what if you're in the mood for something
even unhealthier well this right here is
the double
smoke shack burger and it's the most
calorific standard burger
at shake shack clocks in at 870 calories
just the burger this is also the menu
item with the highest fat content
in the us one of these contains 57 grams
of fat which is 73
of your daily allowance it's also the
saltiest thing on the menu a double
smoke shack contains a huge 3030
milligrams of sodium that's over 130
percent
of your daily allowance shake shack is
also unique in its approach to regional
specialties with pretty much every
location having an exclusive burger or
custard
however some of these are way less
healthy than others for example
the least healthy burger found at any
shake shack menu
is a lockheart link burger this is
exclusive only to austin texas
so listen up all you relocating tech
bros and
joe rogan this is a burger with jalapeno
cheese
shake sauce pickles and a sausage link
from
korres market in you guessed it lockhart
if you get one of these as a triple it
contains over half of your daily
calories
more than 100 of your daily fat and
almost double your daily sodium
but the most calorific item found on any
shake shack menu actually
isn't a burger it's something called the
double down fries they are found
only in vegas double down got it okay
and they contain 1910 calories
those fries alone are 95
of your daily allowance i mean give me a
break you're in vegas like you care at
all right
give me the fries i just lost my fortune
unfortunately shake shack in the uk also
doesn't disclose its ingredients
bit shady what's going on there guys
give us some info to work with
and that's also the case here in the u.s
we've reached out to them to see if
they'd make an exception
but they could not help us out what we
can get is a list of allergens and it
has a couple of fun things to note
for example there is a significant risk
of there being traces of
seafood in our banoffee concrete and
there are also sulfites in our chicken
bites and in the shack sauce
we may or may not also have shellfish in
our shroomburger
shack burger shack's deck and smoke
shack
so there's no potential seafood in the
uk equivalents of these burgers so i
have no idea why there might be
shellfish in ours here in the us i i
couldn't even guess why
but in better news all our shake shacks
usb
is freshly ground 100 angus beef that's
free from hormones and antibiotics
and the buns are non-gmo
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk shake shack
here are all the us exclusive shake
shack items you cannot get in the uk
let's start with the burgers
here we have the shackmeister burger now
this
is a double version it comes with beef
fatties
cheese shack sauce and then some crispy
l-marinated shallots
yes we pronounce it shallots that's the
correct way to pronounce it you guys are
wrong
for a limited time in the uk we can also
get a spicy version of the chicken
sandwich which is the
hot chicken sandwich this comes in hot
or extra hot if you're feeling bold
we would usually be able to get some
more exclusive hot dog options including
a
chat cargo dog which i think you might
be able to get as like a secret menu
item in the us
and also a shackmeister sausage which is
kind of like a hot dog but with a
cumberland style sausage which is
something that's kind of popular here in
the uk but unfortunately due to the
reduced pandemic
menu we weren't able to get these harry
you know my feelings about the hot dogs
you know my feelings about hot dogs in
general and i will say as someone who
was born and raised in
chicago i would love to try the
chicago hot dog at the uk shake shack so
when i come to visit
that'll be our first stop now on top of
the limited edition hot chicken burger
we can also currently get some
hot chicken bites as well as some spicy
fries
so the only two sandwiches that we
really get a hands on that are exclusive
to the us and not in the uk
are the grilled cheese and the korean
chicken sandwich
okay first things first this grilled
cheese
look at this thing did you is did you
sit on this
too this is ridiculous i wouldn't
pay a dollar for this it looks like they
took two buns
put cheese in it and then i don't know
ran over with a steamroller or something
why is this so thin what does look
actually
bomb is this the korean
chicken sandwich
yo yes yes to this
oh my goodness with the kimchi i'm
telling you
i'm telling you
you want that also the thing the shake
shack in the u.s has you can't get in
the uk are the breakfast sandwiches
we're shooting this like at 4 p.m so
surprising no one
the breakfast sandwiches were not
available but usually if you get there
i'm assuming before 10 30 or 11 you get
a bacon egg and cheese
sausage egg and cheese and just some egg
and cheese check them out
i have no idea if they taste good or not
also a thing you can get in the u.s
is cheesy bacon fries but this has been
sitting for more than a minute
oh my god i think it's gonna come out
like a disc
oh god i want to make this perfectly
clear this is not an indictment
of shake shack quality this has been
sitting for
at least two hours when it's bacon and
cheese on fries
even if that consistency is still pretty
good i mentioned this before
but there's like all these different
regional things throughout the country
so i don't know if this whole korean
sandwich in korean
chicken bites is just in this area
but i think i'm about to lose
my mind yo
you want this oh yes yes to these
yes to these now much like the way us
shake shacks have exclusive burgers and
custards
some of the uk branches also have
exclusive options themselves the one we
went to had a dessert option called the
union shack
which is a really terrible pun on the
union jack which is
our flag now it's effectively just a
chocolate custard with some chocolate
from british chocolatiers however
unfortunately due to the pandemic
reduced menu couldn't get that either
and of course it wouldn't be a shake
shack episode unless we talked about the
shakes
now the uk wide exclusive flavors
include coffee
and caramel and then the branch we
visited also had a cinnamon toast shake
which i'm really intrigued by
mixy mixy
it's not bad very sweet and quite
cinnamony as you would expect
it's so many different menu items across
regions it'd be impossible for us
to cover all the things that every
specific shake shack in the u.s alone
so given the ones that we had that we
went to the three
exclusive shakes we have are brownie
batter hot cocoa
vanilla black sugar cookies and cream
once again
end of the day end of the shoot i'm
gonna put me into a coma after this
yeah that's pretty good like it has a
little bit of like an extra
chocolateness to it it's not too sweet
the caramel flavor is there but it isn't
like chemically tasting
that's the one to beat cookies and cream
baby
cookies and cream whoop here we go
i can't decide if that one's better
that's so good
[Music]
hey you are not going to believe the hot
dog
you want to hear the dumbest thing ever
they're splitting them in half now